I just wanted to ask about what the
risk and failure is within the realm of
impact investing you had mentioned that
certain projects or things which don't
have a proven track record that is
that's the realm of philanthropy dollars
and that's the realm of of grant grant
making when what is the point where it
becomes viable for impact investing
where is there is it for me as an
investor I think you know there are
different type of investors there are
Angelyn masters who may be willing to
put even you know risk capital to prove
the pilot but in many cases if it's the
idea itself has not been you know tested
then you know it might be difficult so
typically in impact investment space
because the concepts I knew and they
might be less profitable because there
is a social dimension and social
orientation it might take longer for
companies to be profitable and they
might not be exit able at the same
valuations so many impact investments
are maybe not as lucrative in terms of
financial return or could be riskier
every startup you know they have been
stats produced about how many startups
die you can say that you know logically
you may have more social enterprise
startups that would die because it's
more difficult to perceive dual
objective and balance those objectives
but what I've heard and we've discussed
just you know a couple of days is that
social entrepreneurs who are driven by
mission tend to stick longer with the
company not exit as early as may be
commercial entrepreneurs who would say
no it doesn't work I have to fold and go
do my next thing they want they're
really driven by mission so they're
willing to try and try and try so fail I
can have a different dimension it
doesn't necessarily mean it doesn't work
one model doesn't work you recreate
yourself you change the model you try
another thing so one of the mantras of
private equity investors is management
management management and first business
plan never
works so I think this is even probably
so much true it for their social impact
investments your i would i would
actually possibly reframe the question
or at least and another important actor
which is or series of actors which is
the development finance community i
think that if development finance
institutions really are being true to
the D&D fi they're called deifies then
they are there to also play that
catalytic role for mortals both business
and funds so aggregated models that work
as a as a means of channeling capital to
these emerging businesses and so you'll
hear phrases like first loss and
guarantees where they are signing
themselves up in some cases to lose a
hundred percent of capital in the hopes
that that some of these businesses that
otherwise wouldn't attract capital so
correcting a market failure will attract
will will be invested in and so it's not
just if you will up to philanthropists
and there's a very vibrant debate going
on at the moment within the development
finance community about quite how
developmental they should be the
argument purists say should be an if but
for argument were not for them this
would not happen so it's a whole nother
range of actors i would just suggest it
we should have in the mix they're
complicated complex financial structures
being built which includes the different
layers of capital from development
finance institutions from philanthropies
maybe taking you know the first laws you
know to accommodate different risk and
return appetites of investors to make
sure that even earlier stage and tested
projects can get there necessary
financing and there's discipline that's
that's required on the part of the of
the development finance institutions the
International Finance Corporation which
is the private sector arm of the World
Bank Group in the 1990s became very very
good at saying as much as we would like
to invest in the second and third and
fourth iteration of this fond bearings
Vostok is an example which is a very
successful fund in Russia which they
seed it it is time for us to bow out
we've done
job this is now a billion dollar fund
attracting purely commercial capital